[Aplausos]
[Música]
típicos amigos amigas de visual política
china está de vuelta la emergencia del
gigante asiático está cambiándolo todo
hablamos de una nueva superpotencia en
todos los campos económico político y
también militar hasta ahora aquí en
visual políticos hemos hablado mucho de
china es un tema que nos apasiona no es
ningún secreto pero de lo que nos hemos
hablado antes de sobre lo que están
haciendo las potencias de lo que podemos
denominar el bloque occidental para
contrarrestar el creciente peso de china
y por tanto el partido comunista chino
en la política internacional
en términos absolutos y temporales el
crecimiento económico de china su
influencia política y ahora también
militar durante los últimos 30 años
tiene pocos o ningún precedente nunca
antes un país se había posicionado a la
cabeza de la política y la economía
mundial en tan poco tiempo evidentemente
eso es algo que tiene consecuencias
estratégicas y económicas a nivel
mundial a pesar de ello el tipo de
régimen que maneja los silos en china
implica muchos retos para países como
eeuu reino unido japón corea del sur
australia o incluso por su tamaño
demográfico y vecindad a la india'
precisamente por eso hace ya bastantes
años nacieron algunos instrumentos y es
que se les puede llamar así que tienen
la misión de unir a las democracias
liberales de la región de asia-pacífico
para así apoyarse entre ellas y evitar
caer en los brazos de pekín instrumentos
como por ejemplo el quad una institución
una organización un instrumento que
podría llegar a convertirse en todo un
contrapeso regional al poder y la
influencia de china si llegara a
desarrollarse plenamente aunque lo
cierto es que hoy eso parece algo muy
lejano la alianza quad de eeuu japón
india y australia forma parte del plan
de bailén para contener a china hacer
algunos expertos no están tan seguros
quiero descubrir qué es todo esto del
quad en qué consiste y qué oportunidades
ofrece pues bien veámoslo
[Música]
los cuatro de asia-pacífico si para
contrarrestar a la unión soviética en
europa se creó la organización del
tratado del atlántico norte la otan para
contrarrestar a la china nació el cual
bueno al menos esa era la idea inicial
la realidad luego suele ser siempre más
complicada
el cual es una asociación informal
nacida en 2007 y formada por cuatro
países eeuu india japón y australia una
asociación con la que ocasionalmente han
colaborado otros como singapur corea del
sur nueva zelanda o vietnam sin embargo
hablamos de algo muy diferente a la otan
que es una organización formal
estructurada cofinanciada y
eminentemente militar hoy por hoy el
cuate está lejos de ser algo así que es
más bien como el cigoto de una otan para
asia-pacífico que sin embargo no termina
de despegar los problemas pues la falta
de acuerdo y de compromiso entre los
países y la gran cantidad de intereses
económicos que entrarían en juego en
caso de crear un bloque llamémosle
antichina en una región que actualmente
se mueve nos guste o no al rebufo del
gigante asiático
[Música]
es decir para entendernos el quad actual
es una especie de foro organizado donde
sus cuatro integrantes gozan y acuerdan
cuestiones políticas militares y de
seguridad pero exactamente por qué y
para qué nació el quad en 2007 pues
veréis la idea partió del entonces
ministro japonés shinzo abe que tenía el
objetivo de crear algo así como un arco
asiático de democracia o en otras
palabras una alianza de los principales
países libres y democráticos de la
región de asia-pacífico ojo al tiempo
que volvía a posicionar a japón como una
potencia rectora y no simplemente pasiva
todo se ha dicho de esta forma lo que
tenía en mente a ver a establecer una
alianza que sirviera de contrapeso al
poder chino una alianza que incluyera a
países como corea del sur mongolia la
india australia en fin y otros mucho más
sin embargo eso nunca se materializó y
aunque el quad se estableció en 2007
integrado por cuatro países eeuu india
japón y australia las cosas no empezaron
muy bien
australia por ejemplo se retiró
en febrero del 2008 porque el entonces
primer ministro el laborista kevin rudd
quería acercar lazos con china para así
impulsar las relaciones bilaterales en
materia económica además al país de los
canguros y los koalas no le hacía mucha
gracia eso de meterse de lleno en una
alianza formal y multilateral
digamos que prefería negociar sus
propios acuerdos bilaterales algo que
obviamente iba en contra de la idea del
cual en sí mismo con lo que ésta dejó de
tener sentido se desactivó por decirlo
de alguna forma entrando en una especie
de largo letargo del que no iba a
despertar hasta casi diez años después
en 2017 ese año en una cumbre del asean
celebrada en manila shinzo abe que
todavía era el primer ministro de japón
consiguió revivir el quad con un acuerdo
cuadri lateral con el indio narendra
modi y el australiano malcolm turnbull y
el estadounidense donald trump
desde entonces el cual sigue con un
perfil eso sí muy bajo
en general se considera que el quad de
2007 era una buena idea pero que quizás
estuvo adelantada a su tiempo pero que
ahora en 2021 puede tenga mucho más
sentido es más ya se habla del quad plus
o el quad 2.0 una versión extendida y
renovada del quad con más países
participantes y más implicaciones
estratégicas una idea que está en marcha
y que podría finalmente materializarse
en algo concreto muy pronto aunque las
diferencias de perspectivas y opiniones
no dejan nada claro que el cual del
futuro sea como el que imagino shinzo
abe de que estamos hablando pues atentos
[Música]
una otan para asia
prestad atención a estas declaraciones
esto no es una rivalidad entre eeuu y
china
esto es para el conjunto del mundo se
trata de si nos damos un mundo que opere
en un sistema de orden internacional
basado en reglas o uno dominado por un
régimen totalitario coercitivo como en
la china acto ex secretario de estado de
eeuu
pompeo mike pompeo la cara más visible
del gobierno de trump en asia
rápidamente se convirtió en un firme
defensor del quad lo hizo hasta el punto
que llegó a desear que el grupo
transitará hacia una especie de otan
asiática que fuera sumando cada vez más
y más países ahora bien es esto factible
sería bueno para la región tendría
sentido pues bien sobre estas cuestiones
hay opiniones para todos los gustos
[Música]
por una parte están los que piensan que
a china y su poder no se le tiene que
combatir militarmente porque su
diferencia en el mundo es meramente
económica y comercial no militar la
manera que tiene china de ampliar sus
tentáculos es además del comercio con
toda clase de países mediante
inversiones directas sobre todo en el
sudeste asiático áfrica y américa latina
una estrategia de la cual la iniciativa
one bites one road de la que ya os hemos
hablado aquí en visual político es
seguramente el mayor exponente
claro que las potencias occidentales y
los países asiáticos alineados con ellas
no tienen tan claro que a estas alturas
puedan competir con china en esa liga y
tampoco tienen claro que la emergencia
militar tiene que muy pronto por cierto
os hablaremos en este canal así que no
olvides suscribiros no vaya a suponer el
mayor reto de todos antes o después
precisamente por eso trump o más bien
mike pompeo buscaba convertirlo en una
alianza militar similar a lo que es la
otan en europa sin embargo no parece
algo nada fácil de lograr incluso entre
los cuatro miembros actuales hay muchas
discrepancias sin ir más lejos la india
no parece dispuesta a participar en una
alianza de estas características esa
mentalidad de tipo otan nunca ha sido la
de la india si la bidón así antes creo
que sí en otros países y regiones no en
el mío su rahman yanhai shankar ministro
de asuntos exteriores de india luego
además no podemos olvidar que hablamos
de asia-pacífico una región donde los
países son tan abiertos como recelosos
entre sí por ejemplo cuesta mucho
imaginar un escenario en el que japón y
corea del sur integren sus fuerzas
armadas en una especie de otan asiática
compartiendo infraestructuras
tales inteligencia e incluso derechos de
paso por su territorio exactamente lo
mismo podríamos decir de muchos otros
países del sudeste asiático así que no
no hablamos de un viaje que sea
precisamente fácil pero entonces hasta
qué punto podrá llegar realmente el quad
pues bien lo más seguro y quizás de
momento lo más razonable es que se
convierta en una alianza política
económica y comercial al fin y al cabo
si china utiliza la economía y el
comercio como sus principales armas de
influencia porque de usar las mismas
[Música]
más o menos estará la idea del ex
presidente estadounidense barack obama
con el acuerdo transpacífico de
cooperación de pepe el cual iba a crear
un gigantesco espacio de libre comercio
entre países no afiliados con china
entre sus integrantes estaban todos los
miembros del quad excepto la india
además de otros como vietnam malasia
singapur el problema es que transe
retiró en enero de 2017 del pp y el
acuerdo fracasó sin lograr su objetivo
servir de contrapeso a china y unir a la
región de asia-pacífico en torno a una
zona de libre comercio con normas
impulsadas y supervisadas por eeuu
pero ahora las cosas han cambiado y la
casa blanca tiene un enfoque de política
exterior muy diferente y justo aquí es
donde el quad podría ser una oportunidad
alternativa para recuperar la presencia
de eeuu en asia pacifico y crear un club
de democracias regionales que cooperasen
al margen de las presiones chinas de
momento el presidente estadounidense joe
biden parece entusiasmado con esta idea
y quiere potenciar sea como sea este
grupo para recuperar el tiempo perdido
en la región habrá que ver si todo esto
llega o no a buen puerto pero de momento
el cual ya ha empezado a servir para
algo de hecho en marzo de 2021 el cual
celebró su primera reunión formal el
cual busca aumentar la producción de
vacunas a 1000 millones de dosis para el
sudeste asiático el presidente de eeuu
joe biden y los primeros ministros de
japón india y australia discutieron
estrategias para contrarrestar la
creciente influencia de china en la
región del indo pacífico incluido una
oferta para contrarrestar la ambiciosa
diplomacia de vacunas de pekín fue una
reunión que sirvió para crear una
estrategia colaborativa y desarrollar
una especie de diplomacia de vacunas
paralela a la china sería la primera
acción conjunta formal y coordinada
un hito que puede ser el primer
experimento operativo del quad un
experimento en el que además se
repartirán las tareas aprovechando los
puntos fuertes de cada uno de los
integrantes con los indios fabricando la
tecnología de eeuu los japoneses y los
estadounidenses financiando y la
logística de los australianos nos hemos
comprometido a distribuir hasta mil
millones de dosis
jake sullivan consejero de seguridad
nacional de eeuu
la cuestión es será suficiente esta
especie de club de diplomacia blanda
bueno quizás por sí solo no pero y si se
consigue compaginar además con acuerdos
de inteligencia no estamos hablando de
nada descabellado de hecho eso es lo que
ya existe se creó en los años 40 para
contrarrestar la inteligencia de la
unión soviética y quizás no sería
ninguna locura que el quad entrase a
formar parte que de qué estamos hablando
pues de los five ice sí sí de los five
ice los cinco ojos que observan
fijamente todos los movimientos en esta
región del mundo pero que de saber en
qué consiste exactamente pues atentos
los cinco ojos que todo lo ven
como si de una película de ciencia
ficción se tratase existe una alianza de
inteligencia global formada por cinco
países aliados y que tiene la misión de
adelantarse a los movimientos de
aquellos países hostiles a sus intereses
estamos hablando de la alianza five ice
o traducido al español los cinco ojos es
la alianza de inteligencia más antigua
del mundo y la forman eeuu reino unido
australia canadá y nueva zelanda
en el momento de su puesta en marcha en
1946 la idea pasaba por crear una
coalición que a través del intercambio
de información de inteligencia permitirá
estos cinco países descifrar las
comunicaciones del bloque comunista del
este y anticiparse así a sus actuaciones
obviamente las funciones actuales son
bastante diferentes porque el bloque del
este ya no existe así que los fight aids
se centran hoy sobre todo en rusia corea
del norte y por supuesto china
de hecho china echó la culpa a los
países integrantes de esta alianza sobre
la especie de cruzada que se puso en
marcha en contra de huawei en 2018 por
sus supuestos intercambios de
información confidencial con el gobierno
chino y el robo de tecnología militar
ahora bien porque esto es importante
pues bien si además de convertirse en
una alianza diplomática política y
comercial el cual se integrase siguiendo
el modelo del five ice el daño para
china en términos de influencia podría
ser mucho mayor los países más poderosos
del mundo podrían compartir entre ellos
todo lo que saben sobre china estudiar
planes y operaciones para garantizar la
seguridad y actuar conjuntamente para
adelantarse a las eventuales amenazas de
pekín nos parece que esto mermaría la
capacidad del juego del partido
comunista chino o por lo menos haría que
se lo pensase dos veces antes de actuar
no parece una mala idea sin embargo
siento deciros que no parece muy
probable que japón e india consigan
integrarse en la alianza de inteligencia
con el mismo nivel de cohesión que los
otros cuatro países integrantes
en cualquier caso amigos estos son
algunos de los principales movimientos
con los que eeuu busca equilibrar su
peso en la región y ser todo un
contrapeso a china pero después de todo
esto ahora y así ahora es tu turno turno
para ti crees que la alianza quad podría
ser efectiva para contrarrestar a china
en asia pacifico crees que el quad
debería ser una alianza diplomática y
comercial o debería crearse como una
gota asiática con integración en
inteligencia incluida desde nuestras
respuestas aquí abajo en los comentarios
y como siempre si este vídeo te resulta
interesante háznoslo saber dándole al
botón de like y si aún no lo has hecho
suscríbete abisal polític para no
perderte ninguna de nuestras novedades
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]